[Musique]
hier marlène a passé cinq heures à
dessiner
elle a passé presque cent huit heures
sans dormir la fatigue s'accentuer des
actifs sans cerveau rationnel
alma veut expérimenter affront certaine
émotion
cette pièce est la reprise d'un ancien
projet intitulé insomnies oui sur la
privation de sonner
nous avons obtenu la permission de la
montée dans une clinique psychiatrique
abandonné
elle s'appelait devra vignes à la
patiente 101 c grande ourse apparente un
journal intime écrit à la manière d'une
pièce de théâtre
ma fille famille de tête ça doit être
plus profond
[Musique]
parfois on peut les voir dans les
flammes parties
[Musique]